scum statistics great great so thank you
for thank you for inviting me and for
all the talks in this in this workshop
so far so I'll talk about something
which I think is the most different from
from any other other talk in the in the
entire workshop I'm so probably so it's
it's still on it's on for a big day
techniques I'm using corsets and stuff
sketches I am it it is gonna be sub
linear algorithms but this oh and I
should say this work is mainly with my
PC students on Michael Matheny and but
this this talk will be in the
intersection of sub linear algorithms so
it fits in the theme of the workshop and
also statistics and also in in so
computational geometry so some of the
like a lot of the nearest neighbors
stuff is computational geometry problem
but this would be more low dimensional
computational geometry so so I hope
that's okay with everyone I won't go
through most of those part of the
details mainly we can do proof by
pictures if we need to it's a nice thing
about low dimensional geometry so let's
see so the the big theme in often in the
Indies you know like sub linear
algorithms is you've got some big data
some some big end you want to do some
sort of analysis on this and you're
happy if you can get an answer but often
this is some maybe it's a polynomial and
n is the analysis so what you might want
to do instead is do a sketch or a core
set of of the data which is going to be
a much smaller set that is gonna retain
some of the properties if you haven't
heard of a core 7 instead of sketches
essentially something more restrictive
where the data set looks like it's it's
the it's the full data is this the data
points have say the same dimensions same
properties there it's just smaller and
you want to maintain the rough
properties of the full data now when the
data is much smaller you can
run the same analysis on it now it's
polynomial and essence said in your in
your in your hat okay so that this would
be the kind of the big kind of approach
we're gonna take and I'll show that that
I'll fill in more of this picture cuz
there are more challenges in here I've
kind of uh I've I've skipped over at
this point but so in particularly
talking about large spatial data so a
lot of data we've we've seen Jerry in
this talk is from like the internet or
machine learning and you often represent
these high dimensional features this is
also I'd say not as as dramatically but
we've gotten a lot of big spatial day as
well this is often in two dimensions or
some low dimensions space these are
70,000 crimes from Philadelphia these
are 60,000 hospital patients here
Pittsburgh
I'm 1 million geo-located tweets a day
I'm working with some people who are
capturing these this is a really massive
dataset there's 100 million of like just
just credit card transactions a day and
these are geo-located so understand the
spatial properties of these is kind of
and sometimes an important issue and and
also we don't often just have the raw
data and just look at the density it was
sometimes I look at those problems but
I'm interested now that certain of them
are our special our special mark points
so they have a value you can either
think of they have a binary value on top
of them and the ones are interesting or
they have a continuous value on top of
these I want to know something about the
this this measured quantity on top of
the spatial data so there's spatial
structure that I don't want to get in
the way of understanding this this
measured property where does this
spatially aggregate but I don't want to
know say okay the data is dense here
around around a city but I won't know if
the the measured data is dense relative
to the background population okay and
yes so that's why that's why I just said
so there's kind of been from about 20
years ago now
there was invented essentially it was
now established as the the right way to
look for these anomalies in this
measured data on top of spatial data
which is called a spatial scan statistic
introduced by by a bot by Martin Koloff
in 1997 and you want to find where the
measure D is significantly denser than
the background data and so to do this
properly you need to actually and not
all people people applying this
necessary follow this but I really
believe you need to add some geometric
structure on here and you want only you
want to determine some family of ranges
and find the object inside the class of
all disks all all acts design rectangles
which which given this measure data set
then there's some statistic and you want
to maximize this statistic over all
possible of these these ranges okay and
so typically what's looked at is you
define some some some some null
hypothesis and some h1 hypothesis that
there's something kind of significant
happening here and you can write down
some function which happens to be some
log likelihood ratio and this is what
you optimize but I'll explain why for
our purposes we won't really need to
worry about what this is too much
okay and then we then the task the
computational task is to scan over all
of these classes of of regions so I need
to consider in order to figure this out
which region maximizes this statistic
you know I almost need to check every
single one of these regions right so I
was fine I have to so that's where the
scanning part of those scans statistic
okay and so this is a computational
issue this is a polynomial time
algorithm basically that's that that is
as slow and we'll see this causes issues
it looks very much like you know you
have a class of very long piece of
dimension the classical beasts of the
classical have spaces so a very small
something can give you in a book a
uniform approximation to the weight of
all the sets yes we'll see yep yeah so
so sure I'll show you this first thing
to try and this doesn't work as well as
you'd like because this ends up being a
big polynomial all right I'm not huge
but big enough that's uncomfortable with
the size sample sizes you need okay so
well I'll show you some plots yeah so
and then on top of this you actually
want to you found the region which
maximizes some function but you don't
know whether this is actually
significant or not
so typically the standard practice is
you run
Yury randomized where the measured
values are you rerun this a thousand
times so to check against that
distribution you built so not only do I
have to search this polynomial set on a
big n but I'd then need to do it a
thousand times so it becomes kind of a
painful operation to do well right now
I'm running on the full data and this is
what most people do in practice so and
then we'll get to RAM subsets and other
things you can no no I mean this is I
mean I have only drawn a hundred points
here but these are these are from
typically people run them on these much
bigger data or would like to run that
much bigger data sets with thousands or
millions of points which until this they
weren't able to do ok the permutation
chess I'm not changing the spatial
location of the data set I'm changing
where the measured values are think of
if these are there's a subset of 10% of
the points are red and I want to say the
density of the red points is higher than
the full distribution I will randomly
perturb where the red points are yeah I
I will I will I will not I will change
the label I'll say this points red and
said this point right I will I will
randomly assign a subset of temper
the points to be read rerun the
algorithm and I get some range is gonna
be the maximum value right if I do this
a thousand times I get a sense of if I
just randomly threw down where the
measured points are I'm still gonna find
some maximum range so I want to know did
what I find is that larger than random
this is how I get rid of the multiply
hypothesis testing issue otherwise it's
hard to know what is actually
significant there might be other ways
around this but the this is standardly
what's what's done something on the
following what is the probability taken
over there's no probability yet oh the
this this what's not not worry too much
about this this is uh this is assumed
that the measured data comes from a
Poisson distribution you you or
something you put some model on the data
right now there's no otherwise there's
no probability the this is just some
model some some functional optimized so
maybe I'll explain now come back to it
but otherwise there's no real
probability and what I've just think of
this is some function okay so and this
is used like widely and geographic
information systems this was there's a
538 article that that talked about this
algorithm okay so this is used widely in
geographic analysis detect outbreaks of
diseases and so forth the typical
algorithm that's used and the software
this uses by is my cold orphan is
basically the same software I think he
wrote 20 years ago and it runs like this
and this is in I think seconds on the
left hand side we can run it up to maybe
3,000 points before it starts taking
kind of hours okay and so if you have
much bigger than 3,000 points here and
you're in trouble but keep that 3,000 in
mine that means if we're gonna run what
they're doing our core set cannot be
bigger than say 3000 right or we run
into trouble okay so we really need to
get a really small size core set here
during when I was in grad school
more than a decade ago I proved this a
little bit I was very very proud of it
but it really doesn't address the the
big data issue yeah okay so what we're
going to talk about this is a popular
heuristic that I have the binary for but
otherwise I don't think people people
use this in practice we have new a new
algorithm that that even beats this this
this this heuristic algorithm and then
will actually improve upon upon this so
and with with guarantees okay okay so
this back to this statistic function the
way to think about this is if I look in
a particular I fix one cluster or one
one range here I look at the fraction of
the baseline points in the range and the
fracture to the measured points in the
range okay and I want to basically the
function might as well be the absolute
value of the differences of these
fractions of the points this is not
what's used in the statistical setting
they usually use what's called the color
of skin statistic where there are other
variants of this which is a more complex
function of these fractions but in
general what we can what we've shown in
various ways is that you can approximate
this by a bunch of the upper envelope of
a bunch of these piecewise linear
functions okay and so each of these
basically this looks like this okay and
how many do I need to epsilon
approximate this
we recently reduced this the number from
basically 1 over epsilon to 1 over
square root epsilon so it's and in
practice it's like three okay in
practice we need three of these linear
functions to get pretty good
approximation so L data so we can think
of just this this function the define
the and if you think the the measure and
the baseline points have the roughly the
same number then you can think of just
the point that's the red points and blue
points and the the range has the biggest
difference between red points and blue
points this is essentially this the same
problem
yeah and this shows that they like the
maximum disagreement a problem in an
oldish machine learning kind of
nomenclature as well okay okay so we
need to now scan every range just give
you a sense of what this like for for
dis now we want to think of every pusle
range but using geometry combinatorially
we know that every disk is defined by
most three points I can shrink it until
it can't drink anymore and it will
there'll be at at most three points
which are needed to define this this or
this region and it turns out so I could
kind of iterate all over all these I I
can actually do this efficiently without
having to recompute the sum I pick every
pair of possible points and then I can
kind of sweep through some some order
defined by this pair and so this takes n
cube time from all N squared pairs and
then a linear time sweep okay so I can
basically do this in and then keep time
for distance similar things for half
spaces that send to the d4 axle n
rectangles that's and and into the into
the 2d disks are actually there's
actually a log factor in this algorithm
if you're not careful but you can reduce
it to half spaces one dimension higher
and and you can get the result for half
spaces and this is like an old sort of
93 paper that shows how to do this okay
so these are polynomial time algorithms
for low dimensions there they're not too
bad and this is really the big
computational problem we need to solve
okay so and this is more general than
just these sets we define the solution
called a conforming range space this
range space its idea is like a like a
function space in machine learning but
we think about this geometrically and I
want to have things that have a notion
where I can do something like take all
the points take it and shrink the disk
until it hits it's the points and I
generalize this called conforming range
space where I need two properties one is
that I can define some essentially
smallest enclosing disk sort of function
and then if I ask what points are in the
smallest closing disk it should be the
same points as before all right so I
need some function like that which is
usually pretty easy usually pretty easy
to do and a lot of kisses and and I need
something that if I pick a subset of
points which is not necessarily one of
the valid ranges and I find those close
the cooling disk and I look at that
range this needs to be a valid range as
well it's different it has now has this
other blue point but this is still a
valid range in my class this is not
always true for instance if I looked at
something like smalls of closing
triangle instead I could start with this
point and I the smalls closing triangle
might look kind of structurally somewhat
different and then I don't recover the
original point set and so I don't always
always get this property but I think
this is fairly still fairly general
Machinery link relational it looks very
much like compression scheme compression
scheme you want to pick a few points for
example to recover policies that behaves
similarly to do stuff yeah so I I mean
it's it's possible I I mean I I think
the first part will definitely be known
in machine learning it's it's that's not
the main result second part maybe it's
known well we weren't aware of it and
then there are improvements on that I'm
confident we're not know before okay so
okay so but still these these are all
polynomial runtimes they still look like
this okay so we want to create a core
set and so the typical core sets for
these things in geometry they're called
epsilon samples and epsilon nets right
these were developed between geometers
and machine learners like paprika Jarvan
Incas and Hauser and and Wells all a
long time ago these if they have
something called the VC dimension it
describes the contrail complexity of
these ranges okay and so then if you
have an epsilon sample it guarantee is
that for any it's a subset of the points
s such that for any range in this class
that you guarantee the density the
fraction of points in this range is off
by most Epsilon right so in this case
they're 22% of all points in 25% of the
red points and this that difference is
kind of your excellence and edit
typically headed to bear their rels
somewhat relative versions and those
don't seem to make a difference and what
we're what we're doing okay and there's
also a concept called epsilon net which
is just that for any large enough range
that contains enough of the day appoints
you you'll hit that with somewhere in
your sample okay these are similar to
classic learning basically same as
learning complexity notions and one of
our epsilon squared points basically
gives you Absalon sample 1 over epsilon
log 1 over Epsilon random sample points
gives you an epsilon net ok so the
epsilon net is a weaker notion and you
need fewer points ok but epsilon sample
seems like what we need so ideas you do
sample
this and also for the the red points the
measured points independently and then
you scan scan over this because you
approximate this you can I show you
basically approximate this function okay
the you can in this general conforming
range space model you can get runtimes
like this and you to these special cases
you get things like one over epsilon to
the six for disks okay it's better for
half spaces and rectangles we can do one
of our epsilon to the four-fifths with
some other tricks in there these are
still too slow we basically need epsilon
to be like point zero one and then s
square s is like 10,000 and F squared is
like 100 million and this is basically
the the run time and and this is this is
this is too slow that's for yes we have
spaces for discus it's worse right so so
this this basic approach doesn't work
okay so it's simple ideas let's try and
use nets as well okay so basically I'm
going to now take two sub samples and
this will this is the main idea that
gives us the biggest improvement we take
an epsilon sample and this will
approximate our our our counting
properties but we need a net here and
it's I'll describe what then exactly
what the net is after I described the
hole with this result we're going to use
the net to induce a range space and this
is a little tricky and you need to go
through these kind of conforming
definitions to make sure this works and
in in a way where I'm going to only
consider the ranges defined by the
conforming kind of map on to the
geometry defined by the net points which
is going to be much smaller than the
epsilon sample right and then I'm by
need to map this back to the full data
set right so I need to define a range on
the points and X only defined by the
ranges described by the points in the
net okay and this is if you can parse
through that set theoretic definition
that's what this is saying
it has the property that if you do this
correctly that for every range in the
full space for every range of consider
there is I can evaluate it on the sample
right this not the full set but the
sample the one that one of the ranges in
the net is going to be close by in the
counts which is going to apply as close
by in the end the function or trying to
optimize as well okay and so in order
for this to work the net is not on the
original space is actually on what's
called the dual range space which I
which I won't get into but if you do
this then you get sufficient covering of
the space of the of the ranges that you
want and you can get this property and
and this works between the dual and I
mean worst case it's an exponential
factor but in in these cases it's all
it's all small sometimes it's better in
case of discs actually I think okay yeah
and so this drives these runtimes down
there's a general result for this it's
now 1 over epsilon to the fourth for
half space and warmer Epsilon third it's
you know it's it's these are these are
significantly smaller and it turns out
that this is how how we get this bound
here which is much faster along with
some careful imitation of scanning okay
so that's on so this is kind of the main
conceptual idea of how these these
corsets can can allow you to get
practical algorithms on this big big
scanning technique if we if we didn't
get the right size core set with using
the Nets then this runtimes are just too
big
we basically need the net to be the size
about a hundred and the sample can mean
the size about two thousand and that's
and that's still okay to get really fast
runtimes
okay there's I should mention that we're
no longer finding the exact best range
anymore we're finding an approximately
best range so I should we should check
that that this actually still works we
can approximate the function and
from a theory point of view this is
initially all I checked but then you
know talking to statisticians like well
you know the is this still statistically
powerful and the idea is if you plant a
region that you know in there so I
actually I choose some some disk I put
more measured points inside the disks
and then I do outs like am I able to
find the disk still even with this
approximation right so these these plots
before tune so that we we found it but
just to kind of explain what this is we
do this and we pre did it many times
what fraction of the times are we
actually recovering the disk this is the
is the the statistical power of this
algorithm and from conversation with
with Airy explaining with some his
papers they showed that actually scan
statistics are in general like very
powerful in in doing this the right the
right way from a power perspective to do
this and so one issue with measuring
this is even if you plant a region the
region you find might not be the planted
region because I plant the disk but it
wasn't the region I found did not go all
the way out to the boundary so I you
there's like various tricky things and
how you actually evaluate whether you
actually recovered the right region but
small Jaccard distance seems seems
reasonable and we can show that if we
set basically the size of the net to a
hundred is pretty safe but it can go
lower you get pretty high power or if
you set the size of the sample to maybe
three thousand or I guess two thousand
isn't doing too well in in this example
here but it with three thousand I'm
getting pretty high power right so if I
set these these large enough I can get
pretty high power and these are the
runtimes at this scale with some other
with fast implementation tricks I was
able to get this plot here where this is
much much faster this runs in fractions
of a second okay so can we do better
here I just use random sampling it's
known in the course that literature that
these courses have been studied and
you can actually do better than random
sampling and the sizes here but to do
that I need to be careful about a couple
of things like can I get a smaller
corset implicit or either for the net or
for the sample and turns out in both
cases it's it's a it's gonna be yes the
RAM sampling adds like log factors or
polynomial factors in the in the size of
both of these but to do that I need to
like these are known and some of these
were for a long time only known
existentially I need to be able to
compute this fast right a lot of the
course ends sketching literature works
because I can compute these things and
basically near linear time on the full
data set sides otherwise it doesn't make
sense so as I mentioned some of the best
algorithms were actually large
polynomials in the size themselves so
those it seems like I might be able to
do better with this the it was not
obvious how to do that we need to invent
new ideas here and and actually another
thing we realize is that once we have
approximated the data we actually don't
need to scan things exactly you can
actually get more improvement if you
approximate and actually the scanning
process itself even on top of the
approximate kind of space of ranges that
you're dealing with and this can also
save you more polynomial factors and
various things so there there are a
number of subtle improvements using
geometry that we've been working on over
over the years I'm not going to describe
all of those to you but I'll highlight a
few things okay I know me there might be
a little bit of more general interests
okay so there this is the for the
rectangles problem the scanning
rectangles and so this green curve is
just doing one sample and then running
essentially a version are our better
implementation of the original sat scan
algorithm right so what I'm trying to do
is I'm trying to get low air as my time
is increasing and I'm even even if I run
time for I mean this is only 0.3 seconds
but it
kind of stays pretty flat it really had
to go pretty far out in time for the
arrow to drop down this is something
small here this is the generic two-level
sampling I told you about before and
then this is and then this is a faster
algorithm so it's really decreasing I
want it I said I wanted to get it about
0.01 air and it gets here in 0.0 0.2
seconds okay this is this is basically
independence this is on I think we start
with 10 million points we ran them
through a random sample to prune them
first and then we refine that sample
right so basically arbitrarily large
large data sets this is an algorithm
that is has faster run time we basically
have 1 over epsilon squared log log 1
over Epsilon and we can prove that this
is basically the one Rapson squared is
is needed or based on a conditional
lower bound ok this is a little bit
Messier this is for half-spaces the okay
so the two-level sampling is here one of
our epsilon to the third and that's the
gray line here this is kind of kind of
Messier and we have another algorithm we
have two provable improvements on this
one this is I think within one of our
epsilon to the one third of optimal and
these are messy and this is not going to
go into the details of these but we have
another algorithm which is really super
simple and if you kind of just look at
these two if after you run long enough
the asymptotics difference kicks in and
you actually get a big drop in the air
here so even though this is messy you
can see over the RAM sampling you're
actually getting a pretty big
improvement and this in practice this
really it really plays out this plots
not the best at showing this probably ok
so I will yes that's right so I'll try
and kind of explain in the last 10
minutes or so kind of a couple of where
these improvements come from ok so if we
think about this again I've got
basically three steps of my algorithm I
create the epsilon sample I create the
epsilon net and then I scan over this or
approximately scan as we'll see over
this restricted set of of ranges
evaluating them on the sample okay so
the story for half space is that where
the biggest improvement here is coming
from is that it's known that there
exists epsilon samples of size this is
in the plane a one of our epsilon to the
4/3 instead of 1 over epsilon squared
and we're able to basically construct
these or within a log factor and in in
in near linear time this goes from one
where epsilon to the third to one where
epsilon to the 7/3 right this is more
epsilon 2.33 right for axis aligned
rectangles
the big trip trick is to approximately
scan instead of scanning over these
these these ranges exactly and so we're
able to scan in basically N squared plus
s running time and we just we basically
you can do these all with just random
samples is how you the fastest best
construction of the samples and the nets
and and this goes to basically one of
our epsilon squared and there's a
conditional lower bound that that this
is optimal although an algorithm which
is and cubed is is is less complicated
and I'll explain that and and that one's
the one that's super fast in practice
that's still an improvement over the
over the this two-level scanning but
with just random samples okay so let me
mention how do you do both of these okay
so the existence of these epsilon
samples for half spaces was known
existentially since the early 90s and
known to be tight as the right bound
here but it's wasn't known how to
actually construct these these were
these are our existential constructions
for for a long time there's a sausage
paper that dealt with streaming
algorithms for these and
you know it says that you know the high
company is a complexity of currently
known algorithms for these subroutines
may be prohibitive for native stream
applications it's a long thing open
question to find efficient exact or
approximate algorithms for either of
them construct because those results
that they do well sit in Houston showed
that you could just randomly pick a
sample of that size your high likely to
the hell certain wells are were epsilon
nets rights for epsilon samples is what
I want to get here right and this is so
that was that basically there are these
discrepancy based approaches and the
best bounds here were were not
constructive for a long time
so Bansal this important stock of fox
2010 paper which basically made all
these things constructive they'd relied
on the pigeonhole principle and the
proof and and then there's been some
refinement over the year there's this
several papers along lines
I guess Kasper Larson may have a and
maybe some other authors have some
papers that maybe don't use an SP peer
anymore but they're still basically
these become like the size of the data
times one over epsilon to the fourth
runtime which is is is bigger than than
what we want okay so we they can get
these but they're but they the runtime
is too big yeah how do you define an
epsilon sample again is it the sample
size that the fraction of once within
your set
87 on the way from the the real fraction
yes for it for every for every every set
in the class yeah as I was saying okay
the class is
BC then random sample sugar day but they
only gives me one over epsilon squared
and that size shows up in the runtime
and and so that turns out to be the the
bottleneck in the sacrificing right so
if I can reduce this the downstream I
will run faster end and this this leads
to this difference in then the plots
that I that I showed you and and it
turns out it's it's pretty easy to do
this surprise this that okay there's a
thing construction geometry known as ATZ
partition as or just just a partition so
to find with respect to range spaces but
you can but you can think of this for a
house spaces in 2d and what is is a
decomposition the point set into these
cells and these and these subsets so
each cell contains the subset the cells
may overlap but the subsets are going to
be disjoint they're all approximately
the same size and the property is that
any any half space boundary crosses at
most heat to the Z of these I'm not sure
if it's every VC class but it's it's
more general than half spaces you can
define these I think I mean like you can
do for dis through lifting but I I think
you can I'm not sure if it's every VC
class but it's more general than half
spaces okay so you'll pitch of the
partition is creates the triangles in
the picture yeah speak to all these
spaces yeah yeah and this has been
studied this these are very classic
results in geometry basically a to check
kind of basically had a good solution in
in the early 90s refined by Chan and ten
years ago and basically you can get a Z
equals one-half partition in in close to
linear time okay and but they're even he
even all the results the
kind of came up in this in data
structure literature these are the core
of under same days structures for
half-space queries basically and and
before that there are older results I
had weaker values on Z and I'll get back
to these okay yeah so so actually I'll
tell you right now these are actually
much simpler the the these approaches
behind the two chicken Chan are pretty
complicated
we actually my student actually
implemented them it took him like nine
months to do so and I I'm I could have
taken a lot longer he's he's pretty I
would who have taken me a lot longer
than nine months they're they're very
complicated I don't think anyone has
their core structure but I think no
one's implemented them before okay so so
but this we we we realize this
afterwards this structure is much
simpler the bound on Z and then the
corset size isn't as good as good but
it's simpler the ideas basically is hey
you queued to build build a KD tree so
you split verdict vertically and then
you split horizontally except the second
split the the horizontal split has to be
a single line okay so I have to have
what's called a ham sandwich cut here so
it has roughly half the points on either
side but it's a single line going
through okay and you can do this in
linear time where you can sample a
couple things and gives you good
approximation and then recursively on
down so every recursive split is with
this I can just use media in the second
one I into a ham sandwich split and then
this refinement is it's all ham sandwich
splits okay and and so and then the
partition is just the cells of this
that's it so I can build this very very
quickly okay now once I have a partition
the the new idea is that this gives you
a epsilon sample very easily for each
cell in the partition I choose one point
at random that's it so now we have a
fast construction the proof is actually
is is is very simple there's only some
number of these cells which are cut and
so it's just
just a hot thing down right there's some
number which are cut which is not too
big
each of them has you know a small number
of things in them you plug it in here
you and you get this right so it's it's
a very very simple proof you know those
yeah there's an extra log factor here
which is non-optimal which is less it's
actually less than one lock that we're
not optimal by but but it's now near
linear time instead of some polynomial
in the in the size of the set you get
which which matters okay so this was the
very simple result okay and and this so
basically the ham sandwich tree cut is
is this purple one which is doing really
well these these other cuttings we can
actually get to be competitive with the
random sampling which I'm very proud of
but it's not actually pretty much in
this result and I think I'm out of time
so I'll skip the the rectangle scanning
but this you can do faster by you define
and a an adaptive grid and then you just
need to solve something nearby in the
grid this is where the approximation
comes in and then you can scan it just
this is the one of epsilon to the third
time because in every strip here you can
do this in in linear time and this so
it's but some some trick here okay and
this gets that gets this improvement
down here
okay so faster scanning makes a big
difference in their rectangles okay but
all I think I'm out of time so I owe and
here and say a lot of this work was was
my soon Mike Matheny who implemented and
came up with with kind of the core of
most the proofs the rectangles is
conditionally tight reduced to all pairs
shortest path there's there's there's an
iCal paper which basically showed that
for the exact case a few years ago we
think the half-spaces we can get to this
although we've alternated between
thinking that this was the right bound
as well
or maybe I think we had a conjecture
that was like one ninth less than that
it was like and that's why reps on the
one ninth less than that but and all the
codes on on is also I get up okay so
I'll stop here
[Applause]